hello and welcome to our 2010 meeting it
's thursday 28th november
i have a few announcements offered before
taking your questions i only had
the iphone explains johanna on the contents
of
nice guarantees - millions business is love
it takes  now scenes after 6 in
full of good news approaches
christmas the european commission
today released the 2019 edition
of the consumer conditions scoreboard is
the latest figures show that more
than 70% of consumers
trust retailers in the  retailers
to respect their rights and they
also show that efforts are
still needed to improve
consumption conditions and the
dashboards also show
that consumers consumers are
more aware of their
environmental footprint
a press release with  all the
survey results are available
online
here it was but announcement for
today  i will see